PROFESSOR: That I know of that
derives two-dimensional
symmetries.
And so, what I will give you
instead is a set of notes--
nothing fancy, just
handwritten--
but which will carry out each of
the derivations in detail,
so you'll have something to
fall back on if it seems
overly complicated.
Any questions on what we've
done to this point?
We've really set forth the
ground rules and components of
our final step.
And that, as I mentioned
earlier, is to combine one or
more of these collections of
symmetry elements around a
fixed point in space, with one
of the five two-dimensional
lattices that can accommodate
them.
And when we find a successful,
feasible combination, we will
have derived something that we
could call the two-dimensional
crystallographic space groups.
These are collections of
operations which really pick
up everything-- the
whole space--
move it, tumble it end over end,
and throw it back down
into coincidence with itself.
So hence the term space group,
rather than point group, where
it's only a point that's left
invariant at worst.
OK, so what we're going to do
then is to take each of the
point groups in turn, and
combine each of them, when
possible, with one of the
five lattice types.
And I remind you that those
are the oblique lattice or
parallelogram lattice.
And this was what was required
by two and one,
no symmetry at all.
Then there was the primitive
rectangular net, and the
symmetry element that required
that was a mirror plane, or we
could have, depending on how the
mirror plane was aligned
relative to the translation, we
could also have a lattice
that was non-primitive,
a double cell.
And that was a centered
rectangular net.
And either of those
was compatible
with a mirror plane.
Then we had a square cell--
square net or square cell-- and
that was what was required
by a 4-fold axis.
And then the hexagonal net, and
that could be required by
either a 3-fold or a 6-fold.
Well, if you add up the number
of point groups that we've
listed here, there are only
six, but there are 10
crystallographic point groups.
So what about the ones that we
have not yet considered adding
to a lattice, and these are
the nets of the form Cnv.
So let's consider, in turn, each
of those point groups and
see what they would require
of the lattice that could
accommodate them.
But let's do 2MM first.
2MM, the 2 is compatible
with an oblique net.
The mirror plane wants either
a rectangular net or a
centered rectangular net.
So all we can do is to add
this to a rectangular or
centered rectangular net.
Let's put a 2-fold axis
at the lattice point.
The mirror plane has to be
aligned along the edge of a
rectangular net.
If there are two of them, you
just put one along each of the
edges of the rectangular net.
A mirror plane in a net could
either go in like this, or
could go, for the centered
net, in like this.
So what we're saying, 2-fold
doesn't care, add a mirror
plane, it means that
the parallelogram
has to become a rectangle.
You can put the two mirror
planes of 2MM in along the two
edges of the rectangle, or do
this equally well with a
centered rectangular net, put
the mirror plane in parallel
to the edges, just like we did
in CM, put the 2-fold axis in
at the lattice points.
So there's a lattice point at
the corner, and also a lattice
point in the middle
of the cell.
So for the rectangular net, we
could put in either M or 2MM
in both of these rectangular
nets, the
primitive and the centered.
4-fold access requires that
the net become still more
specialized and have the
shape of a square.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: We can't
see on this side.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
I'll pace back and forth,
which I usually do.
Then everybody will
get equal time.
OK, so I'm glad you spoke up.
4-fold axis requires
a square net.
There are two mirror planes,
45 degrees apart, and those
mirror planes have to be
along the edges of
a rectangular net.
Put one of them in this
orientation, and that surely
is along the edge of a
rectangular net, along the
edge of a net that's not only
rectangular but square.
But it has a higher symmetry,
and that's fine.
Looks as though this diagonal
mirror plane might cause
troubles, but let's note that
if we look at the diagonal
translations in this lattice,
that they will define a
centered rectangular net, so
putting the other mirror plane
in this way puts it along
the edge of a
centered rectangular net.
So this mirror plane is
perfectly happy as well.
So in the square lattice
we could pop either
symmetry 4 or 4MM.
3-fold is an interesting one.
That's the odd symmetry that
does strange things.
Here is a hexagonal net,
and that's what
a 3-fold axis requires.
Two translations, identical in
magnitude, and in terms of
what goes on along them, in
exactly 120 degrees apart.
Now, I don't readily see any
rectangle along the edge of
which I could align the
mirror plane in 3M.
But it's the oblique shape of
this net that throws you off.
Let's notice that if I draw
several unit cells side by
side, here is a double cell that
has a rectangular shape.
OK?
Take 2T1 plus T2 as one edge
of the cell, and leave the
other one as T2, and we have
defined a cell where that is
identically a 90-degree angle.
So one of the mirror planes
of 3M could go in this
orientation, and the other one
would be 30 degrees away.
So this would be the
orientation of
the two mirror planes.
So we're putting in 3M with
M perpendicular to the
translations that define
the primitive hexagonal
cell, T1 and T2.
But there's another
way you can do it.
Let me draw the same net, the
same hexagonal net, and look
at a different kind
of double cell.
OK, here's my hexagonal net, two
translations, T1 and T2,
with a 3-fold axis at
the lattice point.
And now I will again draw a
couple of extra cells--
double T1, and let's
double T2.
And then let me point out that
I can put in the mirror plane
this way and along this way, and
here is a double cell, and
I can put the mirror
plane along this
direction and this direction.
So this is crazy.
This is the same lattice and
the same point group, but
there are two different ways I
can align the point group in
the lattice.
I can put the mirror plane in
such that it's perpendicular
to a cell edge, or put the
mirror plane in 30 degrees
away from that orientation such
that it is along the edge
of a centric rectangular net.
So I could add 3M as well with
the mirror plane aligned
parallel to the translations
in the net.
So lots of funny permutations
here.
Here I have one symmetry
element, two different
lattices that I can
combine with it.
Here I have one point group, 3M,
but two different ways in
which I can set it relative
to the edges of the cell.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why are you putting
two mirror planes in each of
those figures when you
really only could
do one mirror plane?
PROFESSOR: Actually, I need--
well, there are going to be a
radiating sheaf of mirror
lines coming out of
that 3-fold axis.
AUDIENCE: An angle
of 60 degrees.
PROFESSOR: They are at an
angle of 60 degrees.
It has to be 60 degrees,
and that is
indeed what I have here.
I've just drawn part of 3M, and
if I draw the remaining
mirror planes, they
would do this.
OK, I think that's fairly
intelligible.
Another reason for notes is to
draw these diagrams when
they're reasonably complex.
On a blackboard, when you're
rushing to get through it, is
something that's easier said
than done, even though you may
have done it a number
of times.
So there is the job that we've
laid out for ourselves.
Five lattices, 10 point groups,
and we can drop each
of the point groups into one or
more of the lattices of the
five that we have determined.
As soon as we combine things,
we're going to have the
situation that we've
encountered before.
In general, if I have an
operation number one that
produces one transformation of
coordinates, and combine it
with an operation number two
which has another change of
coordinates, there must
automatically
arise some third operation.
And we can write it in terms of
the language of operators
by saying operation number one
followed by operation number
two is equivalent to an
operation number three.
And in terms of the pattern,
this says that whenever you
throw two symmetry
transformations together, a
third one pops up.
You can't push it down.
It's going to be there once
you add the first two
combinations.
You may have to be really clever
to see where it is and
what it is, but it's
going to be there.
It's going to be there.
It comes in automatically.
So this general class of
statement, this equality in
operations, is something that
I like to call, for short, a
combination theorem.
And we've seen several examples
of this already,
notably the one in the last hour
that said whenever you
combine two mirror lines at an
angle mu, you automatically
create, like it or not, a
rotation operation of a 2 mu.
So as soon as we start making
these combinations, we're
going to find a new
operation arising.
So let's start with
the simplest one.
Add a 1-fold axis to a
general oblique net.
So there is T1, there is T2, we
don't put anything in it,
it's just a simple array of
translations with lattice
points that we can put at the
terminal point of these
translations.
There's no symmetry.
If we put in one atom, that atom
hangs on every lattice
point, and that's all
there is to it.
It's so simple it's not only
uninteresting, it's ugly.
It's just a simple atom arranged
in a periodic array.
As with everything we've done
so far, it's convenient to
have a notation to indicate
which particular plane group
one has, and the symbol here
is to give side by side the
type of lattice as the first
part of the symbol, and then
the point group that
you have added.
So what do we have here?
We've taken a primitive oblique
lattice, and we've
added no symmetry at
all, a 1-fold axis.
And here people who have derived
symmetry theory assume
that the reader knows
something.
And so you're going to get a lot
of respect when you show
your colleagues that you know
what this notation means.
All you have to do, if you know
the symmetry, is to state
whether the lattice is
primitive, as it has to be for
an oblique net, or whether it's
centered, in the case of
the rectangular net.
Three dimensions is a lot
more complicated.
If the lattice is cubic, it
could be primitive, it could
be face-centered, it could
be body-centered.
So you need a symbol that tells
the type of lattice.
In this case it's primitive, and
the point group that we've
added is 1, so this rather
boring ugly thing
here is called P1.
Another bit of code.
We're going to do eventually
the same thing in three
dimensions.
We're going to take just
a general oblique
three-dimensional lattice, and
not adorn it with any sort of
symmetry at all, and that
will also be called P1.
But to distinguish the two,
capital P1 means a
three-dimensional lattice, and
we won't be working with those
for a while.
We haven't even enumerated
them.
A lowercase p, that is
the symbol for a
two-dimensional net.
In other words, a plane group
rather than a space group.
So here's the first, P1, and it
really doesn't give shivers
running up and down my
spine to look at it.
So let's do one that's a little
more interesting.
Let's take a 2-fold axis and
combine it first with a
primitive rectangular net.
I'm sorry, what am I saying?
I want an oblique net.
So the symbol--
and I'm assuming this is going
to be unique, and we haven't
seen anything with a 2-fold
axis in it, so it is.
So this would be P for a
primitive lattice, 2 for the
symmetry that you've added
to the lattice.
And since you are all
cognoscenti, I don't have to
tell you it's an oblique
lattice, because you know,
don't you, deep down in your
heart, that a 2-fold axis
requires only that the lattice
be an oblique lattice.
Nothing special is required.
So what we will do is to take
this general oblique lattice
with two translations, T1 and
T2, and to this-- remember, we
don't deal with symmetry
elements.
We have to do this operation
by operation.
So what we're doing is taking
the operation A pi, the only
non-trivial operation contained
in a 2-fold axis,
and putting that in at
a lattice point.
OK.
Bells ring and whistles
go off.
We don't know what happens when
we make this combination.
And let me do this in more
general terms, so we can
derive the theorem
once and for all.
Here's a translation, and let
me add to the end of that
translation a rotation
operation A alpha.
In this case, it would be
the operation A pi.
What's the net result of
rotating and then translating?
That's a non-trivial question.
So if I'm doing this for a
general rotation of alpha, let
me take a translation, and I'm
going to make my construction
in the following way, because
I'm really clever.
And I'm going to put this
translation T at one half of
alpha on one side of the
perpendicular to T.
And then I'll let that
rotation go to work.
And it'll take the translation
and move it to alpha over 2 on
the other side of the
perpendicular.
And now I'll let the translation
move to this
rotated translation, and if it
does so, it's going to move
the translation over to here.
Here's a motif hanging
on this translation.
It's rotated over to here, and
then gets slid over to here.
This one is right-handed, this
one is right-handed, this one
is right-handed.
How do I get from this
one to this one?
Only two ways, translation
or rotation.
If we rotate, about what
point are we rotating?
Now I'm going to use
a definition
which seemed trivial.
I said, a symmetry element is
the locus of points that is
unmoved by the operation.
And if we decided, because
these two motifs are not
parallel to one another and have
the same corrality, that
the rotation--
has to be a rotation that
relates the two.
When asked finally the
question, what
point is left unmoved?
Ha.
It's this point where these two
translations come together
at a single point.
That's the point that's left
unmoved by rotating from here
to here and then sliding over
by the translation T.
And I can say exactly where
that rotation is.
It's going to be along the
perpendicular bisector of my
original translation.
And where is it going
to be located?
This line makes an angle of
alpha over 2 with respect to
the perpendicular to
T. So that angle is
also alpha over 2.
This line and this line both
make an angle of alpha over 2
relative to the normal to the
translation, so this angle is
also alpha over 2.
And look how this
has turned out.
The combination of a rotation
with a translation is another
rotation, B, about a different
point but through the same net
amount alpha as the original
translation.
On top of that, really
to nail this down,
where should we look?
This distance in here is T over
2, and the tangent of
alpha is T over 2 over
this distance x.
And if I just solve for
that distance, x is
equal to T over 2--
I'm sorry.
I got this garbled.
T over 2 over x is equal to
the tangent of alpha.
That's what I wanted to do.
So if I solve for x, that
distance x is T over 2 over
the tangent of alpha, and I
can write that as T over 2
times the cotangent
of alpha over 2.
So here it is, done
properly at last.
Go up a distance x along the
perpendicular bisector of T,
and you go up a distance T over
2 times the cotangent of
alpha over 2.
So this is a general result for
any rotation operation.
Combine a rotation operation A
alpha with a perpendicular
translation--
perpendicular to the
rotation axis A--
and the result is a new rotation
operation through the
same angle, but at a
different location.
It's at a distance x, which is
equal to T over 2 times the
cotangent of alpha over 2
along the perpendicular
bisector of T.
So this is a general theorem.
This is a fact of
two-dimensional life that is
always going to be true
regardless of alpha.
And the only constraint is that
the translation has to be
added perpendicular to the locus
of the rotation axis,
and that has to be the case in
two dimensions, because the
rotation axis has to always be
normal to the space, the
two-dimensional space.
In three dimensions, we'll have
to generalize this to
make the translation have
arbitrary orientation relative
to the rotation axis, but we've
got enough to chew on at
the moment.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The distance x is
the distance up along the
perpendicular bisector.
I'm sorry.
I said it but I didn't
write it in.
OK?
Let me go through it again
since we've got
everything on the board.
We start with the original
object, rotate it by alpha,
and then we then further map
it to a new location by the
translation T.
Both motifs are right-handed,
but they're not parallel, so
therefore, they have to be
related by a rotation.
If we ask what is the locus
about which this location has
occurred, we use the fact that
the locus of a rotation axis
is the only point that's
left unmoved by the net
transformation, and the place
where this translation
intersects the translation that
has been shifted over by
T is a point that sits up
along the perpendicular
bisector of the translation by
a distance T over 2 times the
cotangent of alpha over 2.
So that's in the abstract.
Let's now look at a particular
application of this to our
addition of a 2-fold rotation
to a translation.
So here's the translation T.
We're going to put a 2-fold
axis and the only operation
which it
possesses, namely A pi.
And according to our theorem,
up along the perpendicular
bisector of T by distance x
equals T over 2 times the
cotangent of alpha over
2 should be a
new operation B pi.
So in this case, this would be
T over 2 times the cotangent
of pi over 2.
Cotangent of 90 degrees is 0.
So this says that you go
0 of the way along the
perpendicular bisector, which
means you stay right at the
midpoint of T. So this says that
if you rotate through 180
degrees, follow that by this
translation, you should find
that the net effect is a
rotation of pi over 2 about
this point.
Boggles the mind, but let's
show that it works.
Here is an initial point,
initial motif number 1, and it
is right-handed.
We rotate by 180 degrees.
Here's number 2, it stays
right-handed, and I pick it up
and I move it by this
translation, and it moves from
here to here.
Here's number 3, it stayed
right-handed, and the way I
get from 1 to 3 in one shot is
to rotate 180 degrees about
the midpoint of the
translation.
How about that?
People are so astounded that
they're stunned, except for
the people who couldn't see what
I was doing, and they're
moving back and forth
frantically trying
to see what I wrote.
I'll let you catch your breath,
and then let's do
this, use this to derive the
two-dimensional space group,
the plane group that results
when we add a 2-fold access to
an oblique net.
And it's turned out very simply,
because if I've got
the operation B pi here, that
implies that I've got a 2-fold
axis, because that's the only
operation that exists within a
2-fold axis.
So I'll start by putting
in a 2-fold axis here.
I'll combine A pi with this
translation T1, I get a new
rotation operation, B pi,
in the middle of this
translation, so there's a
new 2-fold axis there.
The 2-fold axis here hanging at
this lattice point as well,
and at these other
lattice points.
Combine the rotation A pi with
this translation T2, I get a
new operation, B pi, sitting
in the middle of this
translation, so I've got all I
need to say that there's a
2-fold axis there.
That 2-fold axis will get
translated down here by T1.
This 2-fold axis will be
translated over to here by T2.
Then the only other thing that
I have to combine this
translation with is the
translation T1 plus T2, and
that combined with A pi says I
should have B pi in the middle
of that translation as well,
so I'll get another 2-fold
axis in the middle
of the cell.
And that's it.
We've got our first nontrivial
two-dimensional space group.
And what do we call this?
Confusing as hell, some might
say, but crystallographers
would say that it's a primitive
lattice combined
with a 2-fold axis,
this is P2.
I don't have to tell you that
it's an oblique net, because
you know that that is all that
a 2-fold axis requires, that
the net be oblique.
What does the pattern
look like?
I'll say another thing that's
so simple, it takes a while
for it to sink in.
The pattern of a plane group
is the pattern that is
generated by the point group
merely hung at every lattice
point in the net.
So if this is what a 2-fold axis
does, relates a pair of
motifs like this, a pattern for
P2 is this pair hung at
every lattice point.
So all of the objects are of the
same pirality, all either
left-handed or right-handed.
I've got the same pair at every
corner of the cell.
And notice that these new
symmetry elements that popped
up just like what we found in
the point groups, the new
mirror planes that came arose
as a consequence of the
combination that we had made.
And they were independent in
most cases, 3M being the one
case where they weren't.
These additional three
2-fold axes are
independent 2-fold axes.
They're different kinds of
2-fold axes than the ones at
the corner.
Not only are they not equivalent
by translation, but
they do different things
relative to the motifs that
are in the pattern.
This 2-fold axis has a different
relation relative to
the two closest motifs
than does this one,
than does this one.
They relate different objects
pairwise in the pattern.
And no two of these 2-fold
axes describe the same
pairwise relationship.
So these are independent
2-fold axes.
Independent in the sense that
they do different things
relative to the motifs in the
pattern, different in the
sense that there is no other
operation that throws this one
into this one, and therefore,
of necessity, would require
that the pair about this 2-fold
axis be the same as the
pair about this 2-fold axis.
OK.
So there is a first nontrivial
two-dimensional space group.
I should mention--
probably an obvious fact--
that this also has a cousin
in three dimensions.
If I just imagine all of these
2-fold axes extending out
through space perpendicular to
the plane of the blackboard,
and take another translation
that is also perpendicular to
the blackboard, I would have
the three-dimensional space
group which has the same symbol
except capital P,
indicating that it's
a space lattice.
So almost at no extra charge,
we've done all the work to
determine one of the
three-dimensional space groups.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you change the
order of the combination of
the translation rotation, do
we get the same operation?
PROFESSOR: OK.
That is a good question.
I really meant to mention it
earlier in connection with the
point groups.
Does interchange of the order
of the operations in a
combination change the result,
or change, in other words, the
symmetry element that is
equivalent to the net
combination of the two?
How many think yes,
it does change?
AUDIENCE: Could you
say that again?
PROFESSOR: OK, if we have two
operations A and B, is
operation A followed by B the
same result as the operation B
followed by A?
Does the order make
a difference?
And how many say yes--
AUDIENCE: The order makes
a difference?
PROFESSOR: The order does
make a difference.
How many say no?
Well, this is one of these happy
occasions where I can
say you're all right.
Sometimes yes, sometimes no.
So let's ask when does it
make a difference and
when does it not.
Let's look at one of
our point groups.
Let me take a non-trivial
point group.
This would be point group 4MM.
OK?
So those are all mirror planes
of two different kinds.
And let me quickly sketch
in the pattern.
The pattern is just a pair of
things hanging on the mirror
plane, and that pair is
rotated by 90 degrees.
OK.
Suppose we look at the operation
A pi over 2, a
90-degree rotation in a
counterclockwise direction,
and let the other operation
be sigma 1, this
reflection plane here.
Suppose we reflect and follow
that by A pi over 2.
We reflect to here and then we
rotate by 90 degrees, and
that's going to give us the
number 3 sitting up here.
So we reflect it and
then rotate it.
How about if we first rotate
that same object by A pi over
2 and follow it by sigma 1.
So we'll rotate number 1 to
here, so this is 2 prime, and
you can see we're already
in trouble.
If we now reflect along sigma
1, this is 3 prime.
So in one case we ended up here,
in the other case we
ended up here.
So the order did make
a difference.
Let us look at another
example.
Let's look at 2MM.
So here's an operation sigma 1,
here's an operation sigma
2, so let's first do sigma
1 followed by A pi.
So here's object 1, reflect to
here, and then we rotate by
180 degrees, and this
is number 3.
Now let's do the operation A pi
and follow it by sigma 1.
So we'll take number 1 and
rotate it up to here.
So here's number 1 prime.
And then we reflect by sigma
1, and 3 and 3 prime are
exactly the same.
So it didn't make
a difference.
So the answer is sometimes yes,
sometimes no, which is
interesting, but even
more interesting
is how can you tell?
Yeah, you have a question?
AUDIENCE: In that first
identity you drew--
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: The right side, it
seems like your commas are
drawn backwards and that
just affects--
PROFESSOR: Could be.
Mm, no, they're--
ah, these are drawn backwards.
They should all have their
tails pointing in.
No, it doesn't work, actually,
because even if I screwed up
on the orientation, the
positions are different.
Again, first time I reflected,
and then
rotated, so this is 3.
If I rotate and then reflect,
I'm way over here.
So this is one location, this is
another location, and even
if I screwed up by having the
tails pointed the wrong
orientation, still
not the same.
But here, clearly, reflecting
and rotating is the same as
rotating and reflecting.
I end up in the same place.
So how can you tell?
It's a very difficult thing to
prove that this is the case,
but you can interchange the
order of operations when the
two symmetry operations that are
involved leave each other
untransformed.
And if the two symmetry
operations move one another,
then changing the order changes
the net result.
It doesn't change the nature of
the operation, but it does
change the locus about
which it operates.
Let me show you what I mean.
Here's 2MM.
The 2-fold axis takes
this mirror plane,
turns it upside down.
It takes this mirror plane
and flips it over.
The mirror plane is left
unchanged in both cases.
The mirror plane has the 2-fold
axis sitting right on
it, so it doesn't change the
location of the 2-fold axis
when it acts on it.
And similarly, this mirror plane
takes this mirror plane
and reflects it, and it doesn't
change anything.
So all of these operations--
the three independent
operations, sigma 1,
sigma 2, and A pi--
all leave their locus of
operation unchanged.
Whereas that, clearly, is not
the same for a 4-fold axis and
a mirror plane.
The mirror plane, when it acts
on the 4-fold axis, leaves it
unchanged, but the 4-fold axis,
when it acts on the
mirror plane, moves
it into a new,
entirely different location.
And when that is the case, the
order does make a difference.
So I can take that corny joke of
the mathematicians, what is
purple and commutes?
An Abelian grape.
I can say, what is purple
and commutes?
It's a purple 4-fold axis in a
mirror plane, a purple 4MM.
OK, what other aspect of the
plane groups and three
dimensional space groups is an
analytic representation of the
way the plane group
maps atoms around?
And I see that it is five of the
hour, so let me just make
one final statement to indicate
what I'm going to
talk about next time.
Here's the arrangement of 2-fold
axes, and if you have
an atom sitting in here, and
this is T1 and T2, and we use
this as the basis of a
coordinate system, so this
atom sits at a location x
along T1 and y along T2.
And then they ask, what other
atoms are related to it?
Well, that 2-fold axis will move
x to minus x, and move y
to minus y, and those are the
only two atoms I get.
So a characteristic of this
plane group, if I were
describing to you a crystal
structure which had this
symmetry, I might say something
like a lithium in a
position with coordinates xy,
and therefore minus x minus y
would also have to occur.
I have an oxygen at a different
number, x prime y
prime, and that must then
also occur at minus x
prime minus y prime.
And it looks as though any time
you throw in an atom at a
location xy, you get a symmetry
related companion to
it with negative coordinates.
And this is what is called
the general position
of the space group.
There's nothing special about
it, and you put in an atom
here, you get another
atom here.
This is going to be a nice
economical way of describing
an atomic arrangement,
particularly if you realize
that there are almost 150 atoms
that appear in the unit
cell for some of the
cubic symmetries.
Drop in one, wow, all hell
breaks loose, 150 other ones.
But what you can do is codify
the coordinates of all these
symmetry-related atoms.
And that is a great utility in
describing crystal structures,
because I only have to give
you the coordinates of one
representative atom.
But this is not the only
thing that happens.
This is the general position
because it's general relative
to its location with respect
to the symmetry elements.
If x and y were both 0, I would
have one atom moving to
the origin to coincide
with the second one.
And if I put one in at 0, 0,
that's all I'm going to get.
The 2-fold axis is just going
to twirl it around, and the
translation will repeat it to
the other lattice points.
So if I put in an atom
at 0, 0, that's all
I'm going to get.
And the same thing would occur
for any of these four
independent 2-fold axes.
If I let x and y migrate to 0,
1/2, this atom will join
together with this atom, and
I would get just one atom
sitting there.
So there's a position also
of the form 0, 1/2, and a
position 1/2, 0, and a position
1/2, 1/2 that are the
location of these four
distinct 2-fold axes.
OK, to have a shorthand way of
referring to the general
position in these positions,
which are called special
positions--
what's special about them is
that they're right on top of a
symmetry element, and whenever
that happens, the number per
cell is a sub-multiple of the
number in the general
position, because coalescence
has occurred.
And so they're three independent
2-fold axes, so
there are four locations where
you get only one atom per cell
rather than two.
And then to give you a way of
referring to these positions
readily, they are labeled
starting with the most
specialized, just going through
the alphabet, position
a, position b, position c,
position d, position e, which
is the general position.
And then another piece of
information that's almost
trivial here, but is not for
more complicated symmetries,
what's called the rank of the
position, and that is the
number that you get per cell,
one per cell, one per cell,
and for the general position
you get two.
So the rank of the position is
just the number per cell.
And then, if it's a special
position, the atom has to sit
at a site of some symmetry, and
in this case, the atoms
all sit at 2-fold axes for
the special position.
The general position always has
site symmetry 1 always.
So that's the characteristics
of the way in which this
symmetry can move
atoms around.
And this is of great utility
in interpreting structures.
For example, suppose our motif
was not an individual atom,
but was a molecule.
And suppose you had one
molecule per cell.
That would tell you the molecule
has to fit in a
special position.
And the special positions
are all 2-fold axes.
So if the molecule has to sit
on a 2-fold axis, the
configuration of that molecule
has to have at least a 2-fold
symmetry, or else you can't fit
in one per cell in this
particular plane group.
So you can use this information
to determine
structures.
I'm going to give you a problem
a little bit later on
when we get to three-dimensional
crystallography, and I'm going
to give you the magnitude of
the cell edge and the density
of rock salt.
And from that, in 10 minutes,
you can find out that there's
only one possible structure
for rock salt.
The Braggs fiddled around for
the better part of a year
doing x-ray experiments and
trying to calculate what the
intensities would be for
different atomic positions.
You, in another two weeks, can
get the same answer in 10
minutes knowing only the lattice
constant and the
density and the space group.
So a lot of physical
consequences of the nature of
the structure, the confirmation
of the molecule,
the extent or absence of solid
substitution of one species
for another, can be dredged out
of the properties of the
space group.
OK, I've run 2 minutes over,
but we took our break two
minutes later, so let's call it
a day and I shall see you
on Thursday, hopefully armed
with pictures so that I can
personally present each one
of you with your corrected
problem sets.